news that a black actor was being sought
for the role of Superman and a new
reboot broke way back in early 2021 when
it was revealed that author journalist
and comic book writer tanasi coats was
teaming with producer JJ Abrams on the
project coats told Shadow and act I look
forward to meaningfully adding to the
legacy of America's most iconic Mythic
hero The Hollywood Reporter wrote
Warners in DC are committed to hiring a
black director to tackle what would be
the first cinematic incarnation of
Superman featuring a black actor just
when the film will come out and who that
actor will be though remains a question
as Michael B Jord a longtime fan
favorite candidate for the first black
Superman has seemingly ruled himself out
but hey Tracy Morgan is still available
is this for a rooll uh yeah Superman